over 40 of the population is deficient
in magnesium you're about to find out
that a magnesium deficiency can create
huge problems for your health the
influence of magnesium in your heart if
you're deficient you can end up with
high blood pressure magnesium has
everything to do with the relaxation of
arteries muscles smooth muscles so if
you're deficient in magnesium you're
going to have a little more calcium and
your arteries are going to get rigid and
you'll have a tendency to have high
blood pressure another common problem
with the heart is arrhythmias okay the
pacemaker of your heart is neurological
but it connects to the muscle and you
actually have four pacemakers which are
little cells that have this rhythmic uh
beat into the heart but that pacemaker
is mostly dependent on the electrolyte
magnesium and because magnesium is
involved with nerve and muscle you can
end up with tetany or twitching or any
type of abnormal relaxation or
contraction of a muscle and this is why
the number one cause of a leg cramp or a
foot cramp is a magnesium deficiency
magnesium doesn't just have to do with
muscles though or nerves it's involved
in over 350 different
enzyme or biochemical Pathways some
involving the production of energy
that's why the number one sign of a
magnesium deficiency is fatigue because
if you don't have magnesium you can't
make energy you also have magnesium
influence over insulin for example if
you're deficient you're way more at risk
of getting diabetes and developing
insulin resistance and so if you have
insulin resistance or you're
pre-diabetic or a diabetic you must make
sure sure that you have enough magnesium
to fix that even your mood is influenced
by magnesium people who are depressed
are nearly always deficient in magnesium
another really good biomarker or
indication that you're low in magnesium
is C-reactive protein it's an
inflammatory biomarker and without
magnesium it's very very difficult to
get rid of inflammation and so there's a
big magnesium immune system relationship
the rdas or the required amounts of
magnesium range anywhere between 300 to
about you know 750 milligrams if a
person has some type of degenerative
chronic disorder or a heart problem or
diabetes or high blood pressure the need
for magnesium goes way up and so if
you're just operating off of these
smaller amounts you're going to have a
hard time fixing these problems I think
there's two ways that we are deficient
in Magnesium number one we lose a lot of
magnesium when we process foods when we
refine foods and most people live on
refined Foods especially children who
don't consume enough magnesium so even
though we're overfed we're definitely
under nourished the other other big
challenge with magnesium deficiencies is
is identifying magnesium deficiency or
testing for a magnesium deficiency if
you're using the blood to measure
magnesium you will never find a
deficiency I'm talking about 99 of all
your magnesium is actually located
inside the cell not in the blood out of
all the total magnesium you have only
one percent of it is in the blood so you
really have to understand the input
dietarily of magnesium as well as things
that can deplete magnesium and if we
take a look at chlorophyll that's the
green stuff in plants and at the heart
of chlorophyll you have magnesium the
chemistry of chlorophyll is very similar
to your own blood with one difference
with blood you have iron with
chlorophyll you have magnesium and with
an average person especially in America
only consuming one cup of vegetables per
day you can see the problem and that's
for adults I don't know many children
that consume any vegetables so we have
this input this dietary input that we
need to focus on but also other things
can deplete you of magnesium the big one
is sugar and the second one is refined
carbohydrates
the more sugar the more refined
carbohydrates you eat the more magnesium
you need to metabolize or deal with
those calories if you have diarrhea you
lose a lot of magnesium if you're on a
diuretic you will lose magnesium if
you're on an antibiotic you can lose
magnesium and when you drink alcohol you
lose magnesium and even as we age we
store less magnesium in certain tissues
there's also a really important
connection between your ability to
absorb vitamin D and magnesium you're
also going to have a hard time absorbing
B vitamins without magnesium magnesium
is involved in certain Transporters in
certain things in your body so one
reason why you might be be deficient or
vitamin D deficient is you just don't
have enough magnesium in the diet
magnesium also is involved in helping
you keep your cortisol stress on the low
side this is why imagine museum is
important in sleeping okay because if
you're deficient in magnesium and you
have all these muscle cramps and you're
stressed out you're not going to get a
good night's sleep ideally you want to
get your magnesium from your food so
that would be consuming a lot of dark
leafy green vegetables if you wanted to
take a supplement I would recommend the
following types of magnesium these are
way more bioavailable than other sources
okay and I'm talking about magnesium
citrate or magnesium lactate or
magnesium glycinate or magnesium
aspartate or even magnesium gluconate so
I think now you have a greater
appreciation for magnesium
but the other mineral that is equally
important is potassium and if you
haven't seen this video I put it up
right here check it out